All right next up, hot off the presses.
We've got two copies right here,
two copies of the hottest new newspaper.
It's called "The Owensboro Kids Chronicle"
and Yahoo Life reports,
this little independent paper out of Kentucky
comes from the brain of an 11 year old editor-in-chief.
Her name is Audrey Neel,
and she loves writing so much
that she started her very own newspaper.
With sections on everything from nature to sports.
And you know what?
She's up to 30 subscribers across the country.
Make it 32.
(audience applauding)
'Cause we have a copy right here.
Come on, what would you be writing about as an 11 year old?
Well, I did right a lot as an 11 year old it's called
"Little Girl Lost."
Yeah (giggles).
But this young woman
has just captured my heart
and I am going to become a subscriber,
thank you for putting
this out there.
Yes.
Thank you.
(audience applauding)
And can I just.
I just wanna thank you for putting a word search in here
as opposed to a crossword puzzle,
'cause crossword puzzles are too tough for me
but I can always find.
Look there's horse.
(audience applauding)
Thank you, thank you.
Also, I'm going to subscribe not only for myself
but I'm going to get two more subscriptions
one for Olive and one for Frankie, my daughters.
I love that.
You're up to 34.
Yeah.
And you know what?
If you go to TheDrewBarrymoreShow.com on our website
you can find a way to subscribe
to this most meaningful,
beautiful newspaper.
May we encourage her,
support her,
and get more people to do something like this.
This is amazing.
Keep up the good work.
(audience applauding)
So great,
And now is a pick from "Drew's little Yellow Book."
And that's our list,
that I personally carry
that is very meaningful and important to me,
because I love sharing.
And today's pick is a chocolate company
that I cannot live without.
It, Oh my God.
Look.
Look, we're on it.
Do you see this?
It says "Drew's News" on it.
(audience cheering)
Oh look, this one too, hi.
(indistinct).
It's cute.
(audience applauding)
I just can't believe that Tony's chocolate who I was,
this is Chocolonely,
and they've embellished it in "Drew's News" wrapping.
And I just, it means so much to me.
So thank you, Tony's.
You're one of my favorite chocolate companies on the planet.
I was just promoting you 'cause I love you.
I had no idea
that I would be involved in this but,
more importantly everybody is getting
a hundred dollars gift card for Tony's Chocolonely.
Oh my gosh.
You're bad.
I'm bad.
(audience applauding)
What's so cool,
is you go to their website,
you get to make your own custom wrappers.
That is so cute.
How cool is that.
Thank you Tony.
(upbeat music)